tenter de comprendre l'origine de la vie
sur terre nathalie carrasco en a fait
son métier sa spécialité l'atmosphère de
titan le plus gros satellite de saturne
saturn a plein de lune différentes mais
il y en a une seule titans qui a une
atmosphère très épaisse une atmosphère
fait date et donc une atmosphère qui
ressemble à celle de la terre passé de
la terre avant l'émergence de la vie
depuis 2005 avec le début de la mission
cassini elle étudie la chimie de
l'atmosphère de titan
sa composition unique dans le système
solaire se rapproche de celle de la
terre il ya 4 milliards d'années
ces atomes là le carbone et la zot sont
vraiment à l'origine de la chimie
primitive des acides aminés des des
sucres c'est vraiment des composés
important par rapport à la formation de
précurseur de la vie donc ya pas de vis
sur titan mais en étudiant cette chimie
on apporte une compréhension de comment
la chimie de l'atmosphère a pu conduire
à la formation de briques de la vie pour
accompagner l'émergence du vivant sur la
terre primitive pour ces travaux
nathalie carrasco est devenu jeune femme
scientifique de l'année 2016 en
septembre elle a reçu le prix irène
joliot curie
c'est une grande fierté ce prix est pour
moi vraiment le symbolise à la fois à
titre individuel ma recherche est
vraiment très très fier d'avoir reçu ce
prix en plus gelé reçu de la main de
madame hélène langevin-joliot donc la
fille irène joliot curie donc une grande
fierté mais également je suis très fier
parce pour le symbole que cela
représente
à savoir le fait que les femmes ont
toute leur place dans la recherche
scientifique la mission cassini de se
terminer en 2017
mais avec les données collectées
nathalie carrasco continuera ses
recherches
titan n'a pas fini de dévoiler tous ses
secrets